what's the difference between cookies
local storage in session storage well
they are always to store data in the
browser itself for use later I'm going
to talk about their differences and then
show how to use them in JavaScript so if
you look at this chart here you can see
they all have different capacities
cookies can only store four kilobytes of
data which is much smaller than local
storage and session storage with ten
megabytes and five megabytes and cookies
are are compatible with much older
browsers cookies are compatible with
browsers that have used HTML 4 and 5 at
local storage and session storage are
only compatible with newer browsers do
they use html5 cookies are accessible
from any window same with local storage
session storage or is only accessible
from the same tab that was created in
and then the expiration date is
different cookies you have to manually
set the expiration date local storage
never expires until you use javascript
to clear it or if the user clears it and
session storage expires on tab close
because it's it's just for the session
that the user is on now just so you know
local storage and session storage are
actually pretty similar just that local
storage is last forever and in session
storage expires on tab closed and
cookies are the other one that's a
little different but these last two are
the things that are really the most
different between cookies and local
storage and session storage cookies are
stored on the browser and server while
local storage and session storage are
only stored in the browser and the
interesting thing about cookies is that
they are sent to the server on every
request whenever you load an image
whenever you load a CSS file or a new
HTML file the cookie information is sent
to the server however local storage and
sessions stores are it's never sent to
the server
so basically cookies are best for data
and anything that has to be accessed by
the server in the local machine
or anything you want to set an
expiration date on a local storage is
best for basically everything else
cookies are often used for things such
as authentication information that you
have to regularly be sitting back and
forth but but for most use cases you're
going to want to use the local storage
or session storage as long as you're
pretty sure all your users will have
browsers that use html5 but let's see
how to use all of them in JavaScript so
if we see the code over here it just
says local storage that set item and
then these are all key value pairs so
the key is breakfast the value is cereal
so we can also get the item so we're
going to do okay we're going to we're
going to consult out log that and let's
open up the browser's log okay look at
the bottom here and we see cereal we
just set this local storage item and
then we cancel that log and we got the
item breakfast is cereal but I also open
up this here so you can see we're in
Chrome you can actually see all the
local storage items and you can see all
the cookies right in here you can see
the key and the value right here key is
breakfast value is cereal here are the
different websites to have local storage
that we're on so you can see you can go
back and forth between these two we're
on Estep code pin de IO but if you're in
a different website it will show that
website there and forum for session
storage it's basically you do it just
like local storage instead of local
storage that set item you type session
storage set item so for instance we
could actually change this session
storage and we can change this the
session storage and if I run that I can
go down to session storage over here and
you'll see the breakfast cereal there
too but let's say for session storage
we're going to have eggs and you can see
it changed the value up here so we still
have the local storage at cereal and the
session storage adds eggs another thing
you can do if I change this to dinner so
we're going to have eggs for dinner
run that oh and then I go back to the
session stores over here you can see
that in the program we only set the item
dinner for eggs but now we have
breakfast eggs and dinner eggs because
it didn't clear the session storage even
though it's not showing in our in our
program anymore
now we're going to change this back to
local go here and actually I want to
have for lunch I also want to have
cereal and if we run that you'll see
breakfast cereal and lunch cereal but if
you ever change the value it's not going
to add a new one it only adds a new one
if you change the key ok now here's how
you would remove an item ok so if I run
this you'll see lunch is now gone from
the local storage here and then if you
ever just want to remove all the items
you still local storage clear I run that
and now everything is gone we've cleared
all the items so let's go over cookies
really quick so here you're going to say
document cookie
ok and with cookies you also pass in a
key value pair so I went to the cookie
section on the the application dev tools
and just so you know if you can't figure
out what section the cookies and the
session and the local storage are n
you're going to go to the application
tab here so the application tabs are
just going to show all this so if I run
this and then if I just refresh this
down here you will see we have a cookie
now we have this one that's just created
automatically but we have this cookie
let's move this over so we can see this
a little better
the name is hello the value is true you
can see the domain that it's on and then
the path and then cookies have
expiration dates so this is if you don't
set an expiration date I didn't set an
expiration date here it's going to just
be expire when the session is over ok
here I just created an
they're cookie but I am going to have an
expiration date so the cookie do
something only once equals true and then
expires equals and then you have to put
a date here so if I run that and then
refresh the cookies down here you'll see
do something only once equals true and
now you'll see that there is an
expiration date now so you can set that
to anything of when you want the cookie
to expire which will make it just
automatically delete okay now here's
another cookie here and here we're going
to have expiration date and then I'm
going to have one more parameter which
is the path so here the path of just
being set automatically but now we can
put what path we want to it and now it's
just going to be the root path and the
path is just which which path on your
website the cookie is associated with so
if you just wanted to associate it with
certain folders on your website you can
do that and another thing I want to show
you is if you want to get a cookie you
can do console log document dot cookie
so I'm just going to console that log
that document dot cookie and if we could
run that if you look down here at the
console hello equals true do something
once but you goes through person equals
true you cannot get one cookie at a time
all the cookies basically get stored in
one string file so when you get your the
cookies you get them all at once and
then you would have to have extra code
to parse out exactly what cookie you
want to use if there's only one that you
want to use for that that use case okay
and the last thing I want to show you is
how to delete a cookie so to delete a
cookie you just set the cookie to have a
an expired expiration date so right here
well I pass in person equals and it's
not me before it's person equals Bo and
now we're just screwing person equals
because we don't want it to equal
anything and then we put an expiration
date that's already expired and then you
have to make sure to use the exact same
path so we see right here person equals
bo but if we run that
and then if i refresh this you can see
now it's completely gone it's been
deleted okay well thanks for watching my
name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good